now a bombing at a mosque in the afghan
capital kabul has killed at least 21
people including a prominent cleric
dozens more were wounded no one's
claimed responsibility the so-called
islamic state carried out a series of
attacks in afghanistan since the taliban
returned to power a year ago
the mosque was crowded and the bomb was
powerful
dozens died and several children are
believed to be among the wounded
casualty numbers are expected to rise
security forces have now sealed off the
blast scene
but this neighborhood
is still in shock
i lost my cousin he went to the mosque
and then the blast happened
we only found out at midnight that he
had lost his life
afghanistan has been hit by regular
attacks since the taliban seized power
in august last year
many of them have been claimed by the
islamic state
last week the group claimed
responsibility for killing a prominent
taliban cleric at his religious center
in kabul
but so far no one has taken credit for
this attack
at the hospital the families of the
victims are waiting for news
so many people were killed
some were even thrown out of the windows
of the mosque
i've brought two of my family members
here they were injured in the blast
the islamic state has primarily targeted
minority communities such as shiites
sufis and sikhs
but their focus now seems to be widening
just as the taliban celebrate their one
year in power
well straight to the afghan capital uh
then kabul we can join uh journalist ali
latifi welcome ali
no claim of responsibility but who is
thought to be behind this latest attack
um if you look at it over the last year
there has been a string of attacks on
places of worship whether that be
masjid belonging to people from the shia
sect or the sunni sect or the sufi sect
or even gurdwara belonging to the sikh
population in kabul
and these have happened all over the
country
and
in almost all of the cases uh the claim
of responsibility did belong to the
so-called islamic state so far no one
has claimed responsibility for this
specific attack
but it does seem to fall in line with
their pattern
um
but
the fact that no one has claimed
responsibility for you does raise some
questions right
and as we mentioned in the report this
week also saw the first anniversary of
the taliban takeover of the country
are people reading anything into this
timing
um not necessarily because even leading
up to the timing there there was a
killing of another religious leader i
think what it does prove is that the
islamic emirate is having as much of a
problem as the former islamic republic
in taking out an insurgency the former
islamic republic had to deal with the
taliban when they were the insurgency as
well as the so-called islamic state and
now the emirate the taliban you know is
only left with this so-called islamic
state but they too have been unable uh
to take on this group because even if
this specific instance isn't them the
truth is that they still pose a threat
and that they are the biggest they're
the biggest threat remaining in the
country at this point right and and why
is it that these battle-hardened
fighters seem uh so unable to provide
the country with one thing that you
would have expected from them which is
just security
well i think it's just more proof that
it's very difficult to govern right it's
very difficult to govern it's very
difficult to provide security
uh
because you know you yes you came from
the battlegrounds but what experience do
you have and actually you can destroy
things but what experience do you have
in protecting them right what experience
do you have in running things and making
sure that they
operate correctly and then the other
thing is that this
again if it does turn out to be them but
also just in general the so-called
islamic state it's moved from having
specific bases in specific districts of
the country
into having sort of these cells that
operate
and
live in certain areas for a while until
they can plan and carry out an attack
and then they move on you know another
sect of the group uh will move on to
another area and do the same thing over
the course of weeks or months so it's
much more difficult to find them because
it's clear where they are specifically
they could really be anywhere at this
point they're like covert cells i thank
you for that ali ali natifi in kabul
you